[Musique]
moi c'est bien ce bourg est ce que l'eau
à la bouche est le seul film dont vous
ayez composé la musique non j'avais fait
auparavant et nous dans un verger remis
le film devant berger est ce si vous
amenez assez naturellement à passer de
l'autre côté de la caméra c'est à dire à
devenir acteur mais c'est pas ça qui m'a
amené cet effet mon passage de trois
rounds et michel boisrond m'avait
fait tourner dans voulez-vous danser
avec moi qu'est-ce qui n'avait frappé en
vous
physique assez inquiétant nous faire
jouer les individus louches et crapuleux
et par la suite cet emploi vous est il
resté bien oui puisque ce fut essentiel
avec moi été vu en italie paraît à paulo
afin que les producteurs de la révolte
des esclaves et engagés
et toujours pour jouer les ignobles
trappe les skis bonsoir nous nous voir
serge gainsbourg c'était en 1961 dans
l'émission page cinéma lise lévitsky
vous avez été à la première épouse de
serge gainsbourg serge gainsbourg qui
est mort le 2 mars 1991 63 ans on l'a
tous dire cette époque-là disparaît
c'est un des plus grands génies de la
chanson française mais pour vous 16 15
bourses et but lui as a toujours été lui
quand vous l'avez rencontré il avait 19
ans et vous 21 c'est ce que vous
racontez dans ce très beau livre que
vous éditez chez first editions lise et
lulu dans lequel vous nous fait
découvrir je crois à un serge gainsbourg
qu'on ne connaît pas parce que vous avez
vécu avec lui dix ans mais surtout 30
ans deux rendez vous secrets alors face
au miroir j'ai envie que vous nous
parliez de ce serge gainsbourg secret
serge gainsbourg qui est le vôtre et de
nous dire votre passion votre patient
pour lui non avant serge c'était lui lui
toujours là toujours été et d'ailleurs
ça nous c'est un nom qui lui plaisait
bien parce que il a toujours aimé tous
les lucien lucienne lui elle est à
lucien lui-même d'un musée le gaz aux
siens il n'a jamais oublié qu'il est élu
alors quand vous le rencontrez c'est
dans une école de dessin mais lui sa
jeunesse a été baignée par le piano de
son père oui ne sont pas de son père
était chef d'orchestre
dans une boîte de bombarde très très bon
pianiste mais bon qui dit qu'il n'avait
pas fait
carrière dans dans l'art majeur
le piano classique étant l'art majeur
par rapport au petit piano de bach alors
l'art majeur là mais je vous reprends
parce que vous le dites dans votre livre
on va le savoir on va s'apercevoir z
snob archi snob et quand vous rencontrez
serge gainsbourg vous ce que vous voulez
pour lui c'est qu'il développe son
talent de peintre parce que c'est un oui
parce que j'étais il avait un talent
extraordinaire
et c'est pas seulement à kelly départ à
mort mais
je suis je me suis intéressé à lui c'est
parce que tout le monde disait que
c'était un très grand fan en herbe et il
y compris ses professeurs
alors est-ce que ça a été progressif qui
laverait à l'avant de n'importe où il ya
un événement qui a déclenché sa bombe je
crois qu'il ya eu deux événements
il ya eu
donc sa rencontre avec gréco d'apport
qui lui a dit qu'il fallait qu'ils
choisissent
donc ils réfléchissaient il
réfléchissait est juste à ce moment là
est arrivé un événement il a assisté à
la première prestation d'yves klein
quand yves klein fait sa première grande
peinture bleue sadien il ay la mine tard
une grande toile parterre d il a versé
des seaux de peinture dessus
il a pris une petite une petite jeune
fille à poil et la prise par les
poignets et il a commencé à la balancer
sur la toile et elle servait de pinceau
et tout le monde a applaudi ces partis
aux enchères ça monte très haut et
pendant ce temps là lui qui était dans
le fond de la salle en train de regarder
ça souffre est abominablement et il a
dit si c'est ça la peinture moderne
c'est sans moi alors nous on a envie de
savoir aujourd'hui est ce que on peut
voir des peintures de serge gainsbourg
qu'est ce qu'il en reste à ma
connaissance deux ou trois ne pouvait
pas plus il ya une minuscule petite
peinture qui est chez jane et qui me
représente moi nu
et alors c'est la charge et une histoire
terrible parce un jour de disputes on
avait classé la petite chose en deux il
avait emporté les jambes et moelleux et
j'avais gardé le haut et des années a
freiné mais très longtemps après il est
venu en me disant tu voudrais que tu
meures conflit ta partie parce que je
vais la faire accommoder et moi j'ai cru
que c'était pour moi qu il l a fait
raccommoder mais non pas du tout il l'a
fait raccommoder essai du port de gênes
donc ce tableau et shenzhen
alors y anecdote que je trouve très
mignonne dans votre livre vous gardiez
la maison de salvador dali et salvador
dali elle avait l'habitude de faire des
croquis sur certains types de papier
racontez-vous c'est avec deux camps
salvador dali venez venez chez lui
puisque c'était site cult ouaga
redevables contre chose c'est un
fortement mais bon il y avait des
papiers culot chiottes donc évident avec
son look son cadavre qui dessinaient des
petits dessins
principalement
érotique d'ailleurs quand il était dans
cet endroit là et ensuite ce
s'amoncelaient il y avait des tas il n'y
avait pas de papier cul c'est avec ça
qu'on était censé se nettoyer et on n'a
jamais pensé à en voler un
aujourd'hui quand ben non on serait
riches mais ils ont leur propre étude
mais des années plus tard il en acheter
un il en a retrouvé un dans une vente
aux enchères et de la payer les yeux de
la tête c'était vraiment sable est on
arrivé là vraiment on peut l'imaginer
alors vous avez eu l envie de faire des
pactes régulièrement et après un an de
relation effet un impact ces espèces de
pacte absolue est-ce que c'était ce pack
nous sommes allés
d'abord à chartes avec l'adie drame et
puis après sa 2 semblent aller à la
cathédrale russe qui est une rue daru
nous avons fait la même chose et pour
terminer nous sommes allés à la
synagogue de la rue copernic faire la
même chose honteuse les trois endroits
où on pouvait rencontrer dieu à paris
nous y sommes allés et de lui avons
annoncé que
nous étions alors que ni l'un ni l'autre
nous conduit donc pas du tout mais on la
connaît le sens du sacré n'est pas
français vendus bien sûr dans ce sens du
sacré vous allez vous marier vous c'est
contre vos principes et vous allez vous
marier oui mais ça ça a été le chantage
parce que il a fait une de saison de
trois jours à l'armée et il est rentré
il a rencontré tous ses copains de
casernes qui était barrier qu'il y avait
des enfants et donc il a voulu il a
voulu rentrer dans l'argent tout de
suite c'est pas normal d'être comme ça
il faut quand il faut qu'on se marre et
puisqu'on est ensemble on va se marier
et moi je voulais absolument pas il a
été le chantage si tu veux pas de
pamiers on se quitte donc menacé de se
jeter dans la seine je veux non ils
voulaient que moi je me jette
pas le ballon
alors commencez votre relation a été
tumultueux avec des allées des allers
retours des séparations qui ne l'ont pas
été comment s est terminée j'allais dire
les dix ans officiellement et comment a
commencé ses 30 ans le rendez vous
bon ce qui est arrivé après le divorce
est quand même et dépression nerveuse
moi je suis tombé en dépression
j'ai
fini par épouser le version qui voulait
m'épouser
et donc et et l'huile lui je le voyais
de temps en temps et il me racontait à
quel point sa deuxième femme l'emmerdait
et à quel point elle était jalouse et à
quel point ceux-ci à quel point cela est
donc on a commencé les confidences à ce
moment là est-ce que vous parlez de
françoise antoinette spaak razès à anna
dont il a eu deux enfants oui et a eu
deux enfants dont il s'est très mal
occupés c'est pas bien
mais bon elle est là vraiment merdé je
crois
est
bon il va raconter tout ça et moi je lui
dis mais calme toi et puis après il ya
eu le procès en divorce il ya eu un
procès étape jeudi mais si tu dois payer
la pension des enfants et c'est vrai là
je suis venu une espèce de
deux guides
mais on allait à l'hôtel
alors vous dites c'est du parenthèse
mais quand vous lui donnez c'est le
meilleur amant vous ayez jamais ah oui
ça oui j'en ai eu plusieurs autres je
vous assure t-elle meilleur coup de ma
vie
alors il attend seulement de la mienne
d'ailleurs le seul choc va être le
meilleur pour beaucoup vous avez eu des
témoignages si je comprends bien
alors dans votre de votre vie il ya
quelque chose que peut-être on découvre
c'est on se pose la question parce que
c'est dans votre livre de savoir si
serge gainsbourg ne se serait pas
prostituée on va il l'a dit lui-même
sinon je n'aurais pas parlé vous dites
de sur l'essai on sent dans le livre que
c'est un moment qui était difficile dans
votre relation c'est moi c'est un
théâtre
jamais vraiment
comment vous l'avez appris c'était bien
gillet a pris ben parce que j'ai
rencontrés au touquet là où il jouait
une dame qui s'appelait lucienne et donc
et je trouve qu'elle tenait une annexe
madame claude dans le 16e arrondissement
surtout qu'on sait c'est comme ça que je
les suis alors comment avez vous vécu
les autres rencontres les autres femmes
et particulièrement aux gènes jane
birkin
je ne sais pas parce que quand on est
retombé vraiment dans les bras l'un de
l'autre complètement
il n'avait pas encore rencontré djenné
et il était en train de s'occuper de 2
de la rue de verneuil qu'il était en
train d'arranger hôtels particuliers qui
voudraient et là-dessus jane est arrivé
mais
lui va raconter qu'il est tombé amoureux
de jane à l'instant où il a tenu dans
ses bras pour danser donc bon c'est il
est tombé amoureux mais moore fou tout
de suite tout de suite et lui il a cru
qu'il avait entre les mains une espèce
de créature malléable et dont il allait
faire sa créature lui c'est l'écrit tout
à fait en pygmalion peuvent à lyon au
total est bon elle s'est laissé faire
pendant des années par amour et
désherber mais un jour elle a eu envie
d'être elle-même au site et la ja condom
gers a de plus à l'est du tout et alors
là il venait chez moi en hurlant qu'elle
était en train de ce débat qui de se
défaire souci de se défaire de cela
enfin elle redevenait elle-même et au
fur et à mesure qu'elles versent jusqu'à
la poste devenait elle même elle le
quittait et quand elle a quitté je
suppose qu'il est venu vous voir ah oui
ça quand il est venu nous voir et s'est
mis à rouler par terre en hurlant on est
vraiment des gsm savais pas qu'un homme
pouvait crier autant et hurler autant de
douleur et de colère et de rage alors
comment vous avez vécu ce ce glissement
du gainsbourg gainsbarre j'allais dire
qu'elle soit vous avez dû être inquiet
de voir ça son état physique comme il se
dégrader ah oui c'était terrible mais
allez dire et un ivrogne arrêté de boire
c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible il a essayé après son
opération il a essayé la tue trois
semaines
c'est pas possible comment avez-vous
appris appris sa mort à la radio la
radio car la bio moi je lui ai parlé le
matin il m'a dit qu'il voulait pas
mourir ont crié mois comme
ce niveau libourel 10h du mat est trop
tôt elle avait peur j'ai pas grand prix
du tout que c'était un appel au secours
moi j'étais en bretagne donc je pouvais
pas revenir tout de suite comme il
voulait et en fait il était en train de
mourir ils avaient une peur bleue et
quand vous allez le voir quand vous avez
rue de verneuil je prends devant vous
rencontré jane alors là je rencontre des
gens on tombe dans les bras l'une de
l'autre
non et elle m'a dit 'il m'a dit que tu
étais tellement gentil est tellement
discrète et ça ça voulait dire tout le
reste et je le suis resté jusqu'à ces
jours ci quand vous faites le bilan de
de cet amour avec serge gainsbourg
de quel côté penche la balance je suis
contente d'avoir réussi un homme pareil
dans ma vie c'est pas tout le monde
c'est un privilège extraordinaire
d'avoir un homme comme ça dans ce pays
on lâche pas le bon sens quand on l'a je
crois que ça ne flatte pas que la snob
non non non on veut chez la femme dans
ses bons veaux sait si j'ai passé total
quoi c'est absolue on est passé pas
toutes les formes d'amour possibles et
imaginables
j'ai trouvé que c'était peut-être le
l'épitaphe qui lui correspondait le plus
sévère de rambo qui disait je pisse vers
les cieux brun très haut et très loin
avec l'assentiment des grands héliotrope
oui c'est pas beau ça ces travaux on
voit les eliatropes qui penche un petit
peu comme ça sous le jet
ses trench magnifique on regardera cette
image de serge décès héliotrope qui se
penche sur lui voilà on parle avec vous
lisent levitsky de lise et lulu 40 ans
d'amour avec serge gainsbourg et c'est
aux éditions first et je crois que
chacun va découvrir un gainsbourg qui ne
connaît pas et qui valait me voir et
votre histoire est extrêmement émouvant
en tout cas les avis qui merci beaucoup
pour ce lula
[Musique]